carl jung wasn't just a psychologist he
was the liberator of the human psyche in
a time where most people survived
without any spiritual awakenings he put
our soul in the epicenter of human
priorities this thought becomes all the
more apparent to me as i read the ideas
percolated through his books especially
in a book like modern man in search of a
soul the book is a collection of essays
that highlight jung's most deep
interests he dives into topics like
psychological types stages of life the
archaic man religion and psychology
dream analysis and many more the
collection was published in 1933 junk
was 58 years old and most of his ideas
had crystallized into concrete theories
he sees the power of psychology and how
the modern man is lost without any
psychological guidance in life
especially in the last essay of the book
he focuses on the spiritual problem of
the modern man and he attempts to open
our eyes to the responsibilities of the
modern man and what constitutes
spirituality in our modern epoch young
isn't just a psychologist he's a
philosopher an exceptional writer a poet
and a great teacher there's nothing more
important for the personal development
of an individual than understanding even
a modicum of his ideas
in the beginning of the essay jung
states the following i must say that the
man we call modern the man who is aware
of the immediate present is by no means
the average man he is rather the man who
stands upon a peak or at the very edge
of the world the abyss of the future
before him above him the heavens and
below him the whole of mankind with a
history that disappears in primeval
mists here we can see the influence
nietzsche had in the way jung
articulated thought this passage could
easily be confused for a passage found
in nietzsche's works he uses grandiose
and poetic language to emphasize the
importance and the responsibility of the
modern man who as he says is by no means
average personally i don't like the use
of the term average but i understand
that jung uses it so we can take his
words seriously then he goes on saying
the modern man or let us say again the
man of the immediate present is rarely
met with there are few who live up to
the name for they must be conscious to a
superlative degree since to be holy of
the present means to be fully conscious
of one's existence as a man it requires
the most intensive and extensive
consciousness with a minimum of
unconsciousness it must be clearly
understood that the mere fact of living
in the present does not make a man
modern for in that case everyone at
present alive would be so he alone is
modern who is fully conscious of the
present here we start to form a more
concrete idea of what jung expects from
the modern man archetype the modern man
is situated on top of two pillars
presence and consciousness to be
conscious of oneself leads to presence
but presence can also lead to
consciousness jung is clearly affected
by eastern philosophy and as he ages he
sees an inevitable connection between
eastern thought and the development of
the modern man the idea of seeking
presence and not just living in the
present is central to the development of
the self and going about our lives while
ignoring this truth clearly inhibits our
potential for inner growth
the 20th century was the century where
science helped us realize that we can
engineer our destiny and religion
started to degrade its role in shaping
the fabric of reality how totally
different did the world appear to the
medieval man for him the earth was
eternally fixed and at rest in the
center of the universe encircled by the
course of a sun that solicitously
bestowed its warmth men were all
children of god under the loving care of
the most high who prepared them for
eternal blessedness and all knew exactly
what they should do and how they should
contact themselves in order to rise from
a corruptible world to an incorruptible
and joyous existence natural science has
long ago turned this lovely veil to
shreds their age lies as far behind as
childhood when one's own father was
unquestionably the handsomest and
strongest man on earth there is a slight
sense of irony peppered over his words
it is obvious that he is influenced by
nietzsche's statement in the gay science
that god is dead nietzsche writes god is
dead god remains dead and we have killed
him how shall we comfort ourselves the
murderers of all murderers is not the
greatness of this deed too great for us
must we ourselves not become gods simply
to appear worthy of it young understands
that responsibility and is unsure about
how the modern man is going to bury it
on his shoulders the plethora of
psychological issues that affect us
leads to a collective shadow that
manifests itself through wars atrocities
and a general discontent with our
current state of being we need to become
gods in order to kill god
how can we really become worthy of such
an excellent task
how can i be substantial if i fail to
cast a shadow i must have a dark side
also if i am to be whole
and in as much as i become conscious of
my shadow i also remember that i am a
human being like any other in keeping
the matter private i have only attained
a partial cure for i still continue in
my state of isolation it is only with
the help of confession that i am able to
throw myself into the arms of humanity
freed at last from the burden of moral
exile the goal of treatment by catharsis
is full confession no merely
intellectual acknowledgement of the
facts but their confirmation by the
heart and the actual release of the
suppressed emotions although we usually
see the shadow as an integral part of
our existence most of us are willfully
blind to this existence our dark side is
concealed or camouflaged in a painful
attempt to protect an image that fits
the narrative we decide to espouse
through social conditioning we come to
construct a facade that can keep the
substrate of our constructed identity
stable so that we can keep feeling safe
every aspect of our unconscious identity
that cannot morph into conscious
judgment will perpetually impede our
progress as individuals for it is
creating a fantastic world that cannot
synchronize with the frequencies of the
real world in such a landscape the real
world or at least whatever we can
understand of it becomes an egotistical
battleground that leads to collision and
madness
[Music]
psychology during the time jung
expressed his ideas was still at an
embryonic stage religion dealt with a
psyche but in an abstract and mystical
way psychology attempted to tackle the
problems of the psyche through a more
scientific lens a spiritual need has
produced in our time our discovery of
psychology there has never of course
been a time when the psyche did not
manifest itself but formerly it
attracted no attention no one noticed it
but today we can no longer get along
unless we give our best attention to the
ways of the psyche it was men of the
medical profession who were the first to
notice this for the priest is concerned
only to establish an undisturbed
functioning of the psyche within a
recognized system of belief as long as
this system gives true expression to
life psychology can be nothing but a
technical adjuvant to healthy living and
the psyche cannot be regarded as a
problem in itself an adjuvant in
pharmacology is a drug or other
substance that is used to increase the
efficacy or potency of certain drugs he
uses the term here because it was about
time to disengage psychology and the
problems of the psyche from religion
altogether as he says the psyche needs
to be regarded as a problem in itself
and only through an elaborate
psychological process instigated through
different forms of psychotherapy can
this problem never be dealt with
effectively a psychologist for jung
isn't just a scientist he is the
purveyor of truth he looks deep inside
the inner workings of the individual and
helps him confront the truth that was in
a state of limbo that's why when jung
says who looks outside dreams who looks
inside awakes he essentially points
everyone to the reality of the inside an
insight that can crystallize only
through the proper introspection and
analysis and inside that is the key to
most of our spiritual enigmas
hey guys hope you enjoyed today's video
if you did make sure to like subscribe
turn on notifications and comment below
something cool please so that more
people can discover it uh if you want to
watch more videos from my channel check
out this one and this one take care see
you soon adrian out